we're going to look at a mind-reading
computer
slightly more impressively even a
mind-reading javascript
so it requires the computer to read my
mind
about a card in this very special
deck of cards they're a weird pack i'm
apologies to the viewers that's my fault
for bringing the wrong kind of cards
along but
they are just playing cards they're just
a funny shape i'll ask you to select
five cards
just say stop and i'll select the card
uh that one
this one yeah and now that one
this one and then next three
one two and three
so it should give us uh five cards here
now i am going to look at the cards
um because i need to channel it to my
computer and it's going to then
read my mind and to make sure that
there's no funny business going on i'm
going to ask you sean
to enter the cards into the computer and
to read out the results
so i'm going to put the card on the
table
and then i will ask you to enter this
onto the computer cool let's let's have
a look then
here's a computer the first card to
enter is the three of spades
the next card is the two of clubs that's
already there
and the next card is the king of hearts
and the final card is the three of
hearts
and now i'm channeling my psychic power
all right now press read my mind okay
hang on
five of spades the big moment then come
on here we go
it read my mind okay all right
what's the trick yeah i've put a
recording device
um secretly in my ear and i can
click a number of times and the computer
will
count no none of that is going on of
course there was some funny business
going on
when i was looking at the cards and i
didn't put them down in the order i
received them
i put them down in a very specific order
if you want to have
a challenge go through the javascript
yourself first
and try to figure out what the funny
business is see if you can figure out
how the computer reads my mind
but for those of you who that want me to
walk you through it
let's do that right now or if you just
want to verify your solution
the first thing i did was i
found out whether or not there was a
pair of cards that had the same suit
in this case there were two pairs of
cards that happen to have the same suit
because there's four suits but five
cards
there will always be at least one pair
of cards
that will have the same suit this is
also known as the pigeonhole principle
in computer science because we need to
give it a fancy name for a simple
principle
so i had a choice here i i just went for
this pair
i could have gone for this pairing and
put down a different order
but i went for this then i notice
that if you have two cards of the same
suit
they will never be more than a distance
six
apart from each other if we allow
rolling through the end so for example
the king and the three
have the ace is one higher than the king
but then the two is two higher than the
king and then the three
is three higher than the king so they're
actually three apart but in this case
it's a lot simpler these two cards
are two apart i always put the lower one
of the two down
and the higher one is hidden so that
means that now
if i know that it's a spade and i know
that this card is one
two three four five or six higher
than this card because there's always a
gap of at most six between them
can i use these three cards to denote a
number between
one and six i think the answer is yes
well
the answer is yes yes because look at
this
this is the first combination this is
the second combination
this is the third combination fourth
combination
fifth combination and this is
combination number six what i've done
was i've put the three
down i've selected it because the five
is of the same suit
and i now want to denote the number two
so the number two is the second
combination of course
so we put the lowest card in front then
the highest in the middle
and then the middle one at the end
so because there's six combinations we
can always do this now if you want to do
this trick yourself
and you want to have a quick way of
referencing these
six combinations and knowing immediately
by looking at it
which is which you can assign
each of these cards a number zero
one or two so the lowest card will get
the number zero
the middle card will get the number one
and the highest card will get a number
two
and then we can read out what is down
there as
a three-digit number so this is 12 0 1
2. the next number is 21
0 to 1. now 21 is the next highest
number
in that order the next highest number
would be 102.
so we make a hundred so there's a one in
front
then the zero then the two the next
lowest number is 120 which is the
fourth combination then we have to have
numbers in the two hundreds
the lowest number in the two hundreds is
a hundred two hundred and one
and then finally 210 is the highest
possible number
so that's combination six and we can do
this
for every deck of cards but what if some
of those cards are the same number you
know you've got two of the same
yeah if two two cards have the same
value
for example instead of this three we
have
instead of this two we have the number
three now we have two threes
well there's one system that um
is often used for ranking the suits in
the deck
which is called the chased chaste system
and the reason it's called that is
because it contains the letters c
h s and d so c
stands for clubs is the lowest then
hearts
then s for spades and finally the d for
diamonds
so that means that the diamonds is
higher than the hearts
and that still allows us to then have
these various combinations
great i'm off to vegas yeah go ahead
and read everyone's mind
two billion seconds starting from 1970
if we go roughly two billion seconds
before epoch
we will go to friday the 13th december
1901 so that means that there's
obviously a lot of problems with it
right first of all the networks are
still not quite high resolution enough
to deal with 1080 and 4k video